peter one rule that happened this week a
rule that was passed it's not going to
change the way we see the game it's
going to change the way the officials
see the game specifically the replay
assistant expanded duties you had
reported in football morning in america
on monday that was going to be close the
vote ended up being successful the
replay assistant will have greater
duties i call it a half measure i want
booth umpire i want sky judge i'm on
record with that your thoughts on this
this
mid-level step to give the replay
assistant more say or at least more
potential influence over what the
officials decide on the field
mike the reason why it's staggered
across the finish line is because
there's too many teams in the nfl that
don't truly know what it means
and still don't really know what it
means because
they feel like and and i talked to one
person last weekend an nfl coach
who said to me that
you know there are a lot of coaches in
the league that feel like new york just
wants to stick its finger in the pie
and have more influence on what call is
made on the field and as much as people
are celebrating the fact that
nfl games were about a minute and a half
shorter
in 2020 versus 2019
i think most people in the league feel
like now that that's just going to be
reversed
that even if the flags
stay at a much lower level i think three
accepted penalties fewer per game uh in
20 versus 19.
even if the number of penalties stay the
same
there could well be more
stoppages and more crew conferences
because the replay assistant upstairs
uh you know can can call down to the
field and say hey wait a minute it
looked like he had a foot out of bounds
you guys should
have a conference about that and let me
talk to you and so
i think that's why
that's why this came close to not
passing because there were people in the
league who feel that it's just going to
lead to more overreach
by new york and by the replay assistant
but if ultimately the goal is to get it
right that's what surprises me the most
about this it surprises me they won't go
the full
distance and and have a member of the
officiating crew who sees what we see at
home and bridges the gap between what
millions witness on tv and what seven
people see amid the gladiators i don't
know why there's a resistance to get
these calls right and to avoid another
ram saints debacle that's what they
should be striving for peter i don't
understand why there isn't
an obsession
with avoiding another outcome like that
because this thing whatever it is
however it works
it's not going to prevent as implemented
it's not going to prevent what we saw in
the ram saints nfc championship game
here's here's what here's what one
person
uh close to the competition committee
told me about that purview and about why
the competition committee
doesn't want what so many coaches want
which is the eighth official
and that is this
if you think that an eighth official
upstairs
isn't going to lead to more flags
then you're probably being naive the nfl
doesn't want more flags
and the reason why the competition
committee liked
this
sort of compromise this halfway measure
is that if there is an obvious wrong
call
an obvious wrong call like uh you know
did he trap the ball did he not you know
did he step out of bounds did he not you
know they're going to be able to correct
that now it remains to be seen
whether the replay assistant upstairs
is going to be able to have the power
in a case like in the ram saints game is
going to be able to have the power to
buzz down quickly and say you got to
have a conference and you you know that
was obvious past interference that's not
why this rule was created
but i don't know at this point mike
whether the replay assistant is going to
have that sort of power in the game
my understanding is the replay assistant
won't peter these are specific objective
situations did two feet get down was the
ball trapped as you said objective
undeniable
that can be quickly supported by video
evidence so if there is
a clear and obvious error on a
subjective call like past interference
replay assistant can't do anything new
york can't do anything now look i'm a
firm believer in knowing when to break
the rules in advance of the greater good
and the greater good is avoid another
major controversy and if al river on
it's simply broken glass in event of the
emergency that happened in the superdome
imagine how less we would have had to
talk about over the last two years so i
guess i shouldn't complain but my
interest is the game i don't want now it
would be good for us to cover from a
business standpoint an interest
standpoint engagement standpoint it
would be good for us to cover a major
political controversy where because
gambling is legalized in 35 or 40 states
and it'll get there within the next few
years to 35 or 40th in the mid-20s now
if congress decides to create an agency
with oversight over the nfl if some
prosecutor decides to convene a grand
jury to see whether or not someone was
on the take that influenced that
horrible call that wasn't rectified you
don't want that if you're the nfl peter
you want to try to avoid that and that's
what amazes me they have that failure of
imagination we've heard that word a lot
this year in other contexts but in this
context you need to have the ability to
see where you are and where you can be
if you don't create a proper
pathway to avoid
that destination and that's what i think
they're they're going to flirt with as
gambling becomes more prevalent as the
stakes literally and figuratively get
higher and higher for these calls you
got to put mechanisms in place to avoid
another instance of what we're seeing on
the screen with one of the most
controversial calls in league history
[Music]
yeah and mike i
i understand how the rule is written
you know i really do
but i also think
that
you know
you know how that play would have
changed right there i'll tell you how
that play would have changed that play
would have changed
with a crew conference
okay on the field right after that call
with
other officials being able to come into
the conference and say
you know
nikhil roby-coleman you know interfered
with this receiver
and if they get confirmation from
upstairs mike i know that i know what
the rule says i really do i know what
the rule says
but
if in a crew conference
they decide to throw the flag
you know
maybe there's going to be some grand
investigation of saying that the
germination of this came from the replay
assistant upstairs he's not supposed to
do that
but in that case if i'm roger goodell i
come out on sunday night uh you know in
the officiating department i say we got
the call right
that's exactly what i would say so
i understand
the the letter of the law in the rule
but honestly uh i i just can't buy
that it's not going to fix an absolutely
egregious call when everybody in the
world can see it
well they already had the mechanism in
place to do it now river on chose not to
do it in that moment the question is
with the replay assistant having a voice
in the process will that make a
difference could it be between the
replay assistant and al river on saying
drop the flag drop the flag drop the
flag the flag gets dropped but my
understanding is river on
specifically did not say anything
because the rules prevent him from doing
so so peter we're in the same place here
we agree on this
i think the bottom line is if there's
any chance
that there will be
some sort of effort by the replay
assistant to get that flag dropped if
there's another nicole robbie coleman
tommy lee lewis incident like that that
technically technically is beyond the
purview of the replay assistant if we
think they're going to do it and we
think they should my point is this let's
just create the rule in the first place
so it so we know it'll happen so we
don't just have to hope that someone
will have the willingness to break the
rules to avoid a bigger problem that
that's all i'm saying let's just let's
make the rule fit yeah what we hope the
application will be
i understand that mike but
you know there's
two hundred and what 73 now regular
season games or 272 whatever it is 17
per team
and and you know if you think
that that that's only going to happen
once a year
there's going to be all kinds of
people are going to want
the officiating to be so perfect
that they're going to say well geez why
didn't the replay official get involved
in the replay assistant get involved in
this call or that call or the other call
i just think i i
look it's hard to say
when there is an emergency break glass
okay
but a pass interference call in the
third quarter
of uh a game between you know detroit
and buffalo is probably not that moment
and and so and i realized i am one of
those people who say a foul is a foul is
a foul i don't care when it happens i
don't care what game i don't care
anything if it's a foul it's a follow
call it
but if you open up the can of worms
on say pass interference
you're never ever
going to play a three-hour football game
again ever
you know the games are going to be three
hours and 20 minutes long i realize many
people don't care i don't really care
either because there are windows that
are that are bigger now
but i i just
if you think that it's not going to
really slow down the game i think you're
wrong
i think there's a point where the nfl
has to prioritize getting it right over
how long it takes because of the
proliferation of gambling and the money
they're going to make from it as that
industry matures just last week a
billion dollars over five years in money
for nothing from a tri-exclusive i still
don't know what that means i think i do
sports book partnership with fanduel
draftkings and caesars they're going to
make more and more money had an owner
tell me late last year franchises are
going to be worth between 8 and 10
billion soon as they understand how to
monetize and generate more and more and
more from gambling so
if you're going to do that peter it's
incumbent i think on the league to spend
the money and i think at the core that's
what they don't want to do is spend the
money on 17 new employees when they
already have the replay assistance there
who can do this half job why pay for the
full job and add all these expenses well
here's why you have the expenses because
you avoid the inevitable headache
of what happens when
even if it's third quarter of a week 11
meaningless game between two teams that
have three wins combined if people are
betting in game play by play and that's
where it's heading and that bet is
corrupted by an official who has his
head up his butt and they don't fix it
that's going to be a problem so there's
there's not going to be an objective or
a hope or a wish or an aspiration that
they get these calls right at some point
there's gonna be a mandate that they get
these calls right that's where the ball
is moving and and it i'm astounded that
they don't see that peter
mike how many calls that are overturned
on replay
out of 10
how many how many replay decisions
whether overturned or confirmed okay or
upheld
how many of those do you disagree with
probably three out of ten right you know
that you on the field i would say if i'm
just guessing i disagree with like three
of them remember when we uh you know
when we had that nbc session a couple of
years ago without riverrun and he would
show us the plays on the thing and he
would say okay what do you think of this
one what do you think of that one and
even on ones that al riveron thought
were obvious i remember saying at one
point i said no i disagree that was past
interference and he said no it wasn't
and so
you know that is the problem
with officiating we don't also we don't
all see it the same
and that's why if you create a situation
where you can open that up to an eye in
the sky
i would guess and it's just a guess
that that eye in the sky
you know two out of ten times is gonna
get it wrong so should you really have
the eye in the sky on pass interference
and that's my that's kind of my problem
with an ex with a guy who can throw a
flag from upstairs
i don't think he's gonna get it right
all the time number one and number two
he's it's just gonna make the game
longer
i almost called this a good problem to
have it's not a good problem to have on
one hand it's a good problem because the
nfl is going to make a ton of more money
from gambling but it becomes a
potentially bad problem to have because
you have to make sure that your backyard
is clean that everything is taken care
of because if you have a mess out there
and you don't take care of it someone
else is going to take care of it for you
whether it is the creation of a federal
agency whether it is some sort of
full-blown scandal and people are
potentially indicted for some sort of
tim donahey type skull duggary i just
think that every measure whatever the
cost needs to be explored and considered
and some need to be adopted so
we understand yes there are some close
calls and reasonable minds may differ
but we have a mechanism in place to
prevent ram saints to prevent the kind
of bad call that isn't currently
rectified that can wreck the nfl that's
what they need to do and peter they got
a hell of a lot more riding on it than
you and i do again this is something
that we would benefit from if it becomes
a huge story but it would hurt the game
and i don't want the game to be hurt by
something that's avoidable this to me
screams out it's avoidable
yeah hey look mike um you're right
reasonable minds can disagree on this
but
and and i do understand and last year i
complained a lot about
some of the calls that were obvious that
just weren't being made and clearly
there had been some sort of edict even
if it's only in
you know when the officials get their
grades on tuesday after games you know
there has been some sort of edict you
know to settle down on the calls you
know to to you know it's got to really
be egregious for you to make this call
okay
but honestly as i look at the whole
look at the whole thing in retrospect
right now
i kind of like the fact that
um that it's a little bit like an nba
playoff game
a little bit like sort of let them play
because i think that the game goes
faster it's smoother and you don't have
as many ticky tack calls
and if you lower the standard it's
easier to get all the calls right peter
another thing they need to do is
increase the money for all officials
i've heard that time and again
when
you've got
a guy like dean blandino who says on the
record a few years ago i was
interviewing for the pftpm podcast he
said in a very tactful way the league
doesn't value that position the way it
should of executive vp of officiating
that's code for they don't pay enough
and when you have
multiple referees who choose to retire
to go work for tv instead because
they're going to get more money they're
going to have less stress they're not
paying enough for these jobs those jobs
become more important in a world of
widespread legalized gambling and the
sooner they realize that the sooner
they're going to protect themselves
against debacles as well
one quick thing about officiating and
about paying and everything like that in
my opinion dean blandino should have
been brought back into this league a
year ago at whatever the number would
have had to be
even if it's 1.5 1.8 million and
everybody is like fainting back there
what an officiating supervisor or vice
president of officiating 1.8 million
look
from labor day
to
uh the second week of february
every year in the nfl
who
is the second most important person
in the national football league office
and that is the vice president of
officiating he's got to make the tough
calls
and he's the one who has to be the
ultimate adjudicator
when there are close calls and coaches
are calling screaming okay why do you
think dean blandina wanted out i mean it
was heartache it just it number one it's
heartache and number two it just totally
controls your life
if you want to do that
if you want to have a really good person
at this job
pay him
how many people in the nfl office right
now are making a million bucks
a lot
okay
and
so to me
not valuing the vice president of
officiating uh and not paying the vice
president of officiating um you know a
premier salary i think has been a huge
uh black eye for the nfl over the years
i agree with everything that you said
100 with one small caveat i would
suggest that from labor day until early
february the vp of officiating is the
most important person in the league
office right every game has that
person's potential fingerprints on it
where the commissioner you know
suspensions those are significant those
are important other big picture things
but gaming and game out week in and week
out it's that executive vp senior vp
whatever title they want to give out
they give out a bigger title instead of
giving out big money they need to give
out the big money in the hell with the
title who cares about the title it's the
w-2 that they care about and it needs to
have more money for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports